thanks to curiosity stream for
supporting PBS I bet most of us can
identify this monster
pretty Universal right it's the main
attraction in the oldest running film
franchise in the world
battling robots and space monsters and
King Kong it's our most recognizable
Japanese kaiju
with Godzilla's rise come a bunch more
of these kaiju Mothra biollante King
Ghidorah gig on and road on and we see
these monsters on the big screen in film
after film but these giant creatures
stories have a strong literary and
social history too so let's talk about
the two who get my vote for king and
queen of the kaiju godzilla and month
why did these to emerge in japan when
they did and what was their global
attraction I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this
is monstrum
movies made kaiju world famous we can't
even begin to talk about them without
looking at the film that started the
decade you EAGA or giant monster film
genre the 1954 black and white classic
Gojira the movie directed by a Shiro
Honda shows the modern discovery of a 50
meters tall dinosaur with atomic breath
just living its best life in the depths
of the ocean
at least until an atomic bomb test
destroys its natural habitat and the
monster rises to terrorize Japan many
people took Godzilla as an obvious
metaphor for the continuing force of the
nuclear attacks used against Japan by
the u.s. during World War two Honda saw
firsthand the destruction of war serving
as a soldier in China the 1945 atomic
bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki
loomed in the minds of the Japanese
people the film itself is a social
commentary so much so that a main
character of the film asks outright what
anyone didn't know any even though he
comes out David I think I mean is it
even a metaphor at this point Godzilla
is radioactive from the testing and
during its rampage thousands of people
die on the street hit with Godzilla's
radioactive breath entire neighborhoods
are set aflame with a bright flash given
the United States role in world war two
it's not surprising to me that when the
film was introduced in North America in
1956 as it had been heavily edited 30
minutes of explicit references to the
atomic bombings and nuclear testing were
removed from the movie and replaced with
two pretty terrible editions the actor
Raymond Burr who was very awkwardly
spliced into the American version
and famously bad English dubbing
Godzilla should not be destroyed
he should be standing however he scenes
work out that show the Japanese as both
heroic individuals and sympathetic
victims culturally the best thing to
come out of this westernized version of
Gojira was the introduction of Godzilla
and the Japanese kaiju to a global
audience
the film's international success
launched dozens of movie sequels and we
start to see the monsters appearing in
manga a distinct comic style unique to
Japan a manga comic featuring Godzilla
was released the same year as the
original film reprinted and translated
from the original 1985 s the return of
Godzilla the first English translated
Godzilla manga wasn't released until
1988 in this comic Godzilla is woken
from slumber on the ocean floor by a
massive volcanic eruption not as a
result of nuclear testing still it must
feed on radioactive substances making
submarines and nuclear power plants
prime targets for its destruction the
negative portrayal of nuclear weapons
remains the series ends with an
emotional message about humanity's
willingness to destroy the natural
balance of the world and reminds the
reader that some natural force may rise
up to challenge the arrogance of mankind
other comic versions of Godzilla aren't
so serious and some are even downright
ridiculous Godzilla rage across time
shows Godzilla killing the majority of
the Greek gods
until Zeus defeats him
one of the most recent literary versions
of Godzilla was published as a prequel
to the 2014 American film rebooting the
franchise hitting shelves less than two
weeks before the movie's premiere
Godzilla awakening explains that
Godzilla is an ancient apex predator
lured to the surface by the radiation
left after Hiroshima this is only
implied in the film itself the 2014
Godzilla film marked the beginning of
Legendary's monster bursts which
obviously means more Godzilla but we
know from the trailers that more kaiju
will return to the big screen most
importantly Mothra
I love mom yes really
I love Mothra I would pick her over
Godzilla Mechagodzilla even space
Godzilla although I do love those
crystal shoulder pads Mothra is
beautiful
she's a brightly colored winged
protectress who understandably is
worshipped as a goddess she shoots a
laser out of her head she's awesome
unlike Godzilla Mothra first appeared in
literature in the 1961 serialized novel
the luminous fairies in Mothra
the story follows a group of humans who
discover Mothra on a South Pacific
island where she's worshipped by fairies
two of the fairies are stolen and Mothra
goes to Japan to save them which she
obviously does because again Mothra is
just that kind of amazing lady mockers
first stand-alone film hit theaters the
same year in the movie Mothra hatches
from an egg in the South Pacific and as
a caterpillar swims to the Japanese
shore this journey from her island of
Japan parallels that of the real world
influx of goods produced in and inspired
by the South Pacific bananas mangoes and
Hawaiian print fabrics made popular by
Elvis and blue Hawaii were all popular
commodities in Japan in the 1960s the
fact that both the flying kaiju and her
tiny priestesses are female does also
suggest some complicated representations
of commodifying women nevertheless I
appreciate Mothra because she is one of
the few female monsters who is not
hideous not typically sexualized and has
powers and strength to rival any of her
male counterparts so yeah Mothra is good
and I'm not the only one who feels this
way
a 2017 poll of 10,000 Godzilla franchise
fans by Japan's Asahi television network
named Mothra their number one favorite
Godzilla monster
she really is the queen of monsters
even when the kaiju are adopted and
adapted by non Japanese cultures there
is still no
that the monsters are influenced by
their predecessors in Japanese cinema
and literature all kaiju demonstrate the
tension between technology and nature
they suggest that although humanity
seeks progress innovation and science
there are serious potentially
cataclysmic side effects so I'll end
with the words of dr. Serizawa from the
2014 Godzilla movie quote the arrogance
of man is thinking that nature is in
their control and not the other way
around thank you to curiosity stream for
supporting PBS curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers documentaries and nonfiction
titles from a variety of filmmakers
including curiosity stream originals if
you like guide you and want to learn
more about the real history that
influenced the Gojira story you might be
interested in Hiroshima hidden traces on
curiosity stream you can learn more at
curiosity stream comm slash monstrum
thanks for watching monstrum do you have
a favorite guide you let me know in the
comments and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]